well that mean this is we we talked
about the other day with Eve Edwards he
was in here that was that's one of those
things like and I was saying when you
talk as much as we talk we both I talk
too much
you talk too much we talk too much yes
when you talk too much [ __ ] comes out of
your mouth you step in some [ __ ] and
then you're scrambling and try to like
make it make sense
Joe like in I can't I didn't listen to
podcast with these I like these we don't
know each other that well the thing that
bothers me about this is I couldn't even
tell you the point I was trying to admit
soon as I give us a million dollars tell
us the point you try and make like I
forget I remember having Leon and then I
remember before that I was 20 minutes
deep in this explain why I think DC is
the greatest of all time as a beside you
as a commentator why's the future of the
sport and then before that show me and
Brian were talking about something with
race and men and women and somehow that
entered my brain and I have no animosity
toward it this way I have no animosity
towards UFC tonight well my favorite
shows I've worked with Ken Bryant for
over 10 years she's a good friend
Woodley DC Kenny Florence good friend
biz beings a good buddy
I don't know ease I work with the team
on your scene light I love those guys I
just had Jimmy Smith in and on my show
who works you know there it doesn't make
zero sense and then I was in st. Louis
and I started to get texts from so
involved in that show I don't say their
name and he was hey man some people are
set here about he said and I'm like what
I said I can't even tell you what I said
and he tells him like what and then King
goes hey man I'm seeing online about
some of the stuff you should I edit it
out like no we never do that don't edit
let me deal with it
let me see what I sakes that makes me
look even worse if you cut it out looks
like I was saying something that I
wasn't meant to say and then you know he
was upset and then me and eve's text
back and forth again I don't know him
Brian works with him a little bit on
certain stuff for help or something like
that for shows or he was trying to do
which is great everyone should talk to
Brian you know if you're friends with
them and then I sent evotech so his
number from Brian and I thought it was
over squashed and then I was doing PR
for my pull the belt show in New York
and someone brought it up my man again I
went I meant no offense
I come up with about 10 hours of content
a week I can tell it a saying I messed
up
who ever had problems with it if it's
Eve Edwards that's his own insecurities
which is so stupid
because I couldn't tell you what he
should be insecure about right and then
as soon as I got on that interview I you
texted my brothers this goes you're an
idiot you resurface that story like oh
my god and so i tec c weekend and then
he comes on here right and then i I
haven't listened to it and then you know
I text Eve like dude I don't want to
keep going through this I meant zero
offense ive text karen bryant DC Woodley
literally anyone you can see tonight I
this business especially entertainment
you know it's better anyone it's
impossible to be successful in this
business it's a [ __ ] monster I'm
willing to help them out
I want the help you know I'm saying I I
don't want to criticize people that's
not what I do that's not why I signed up
for this I I just got caught on a path
when you start talking about yeah and
then one of the things that we do the
best part about it is there's no script
the best and the worst it's the worst
that could deal with this sometimes it
goes haywire yeah but it ain't go
haywire my biggest issue is is whenever
someone was hurt by my words or is upset
by something I said then I'm like again
I don't know Eve's that well at all but
I lost sleep over like oh my god what am
i doing
I've respect for him he's a pioneer at
1:55 again I love all the people you see
tonight i watch the show all the goddamn
time they're my first went it makes zero
sense doc and you tried to just make
sense of your words makes no sense I
apologize Steve it's it's all good I
told open-door policy ones come on the
show we talked about in there but yeah I
put my foot in my mouth
and I hate tell you try and happen again
I wish I could say it's not probably
happen again it's part of what makes it
fun is that you are really working
without a filter work without a net
you're just you're trying to have fun
yeah I mean that's and sometimes you
should take some swings you miss swings
I I can't talk balls trying to hit I
can't tell you taking swings at balls I
was even know it as hitting so you know
yeah sometimes that [ __ ] happens but it
happens yeah it's just one of those
things
I mean I've done it a hundred times in
this podcast said some [ __ ] and then I
was like what the [ __ ] I even say that
for okay I don't even know what was
going on in my mind and sometimes like
when you're trying to form a sounds like
right now try to form a sentence right
like sometimes while you're thinking
about it you're like this isn't going so
good hey no let me try to make it sound
better all right let me try to see if I
could rescue this for the people that
are listening and make some sense and
then it just makes it more cloudy and
more [ __ ] and it's hard for people to
fall in just like that I speak for a
living
yeah have you ever been on stage and
he's going through my set and I said oh
I've been doing it so much lately I'll
be in the middle of it and in my mind
I'm fast forward to already the next bit
and I'm thinking about that bit while
I'm doing this one have you done that or
am i hearing about that I know cuz I'm
not I'm not present don't do that you
know what happened is I missed I skipped
over a part that was new and I thought
was gonna be a home run I skipped over
it yeah
and I went back cuz I record it right
and I'm and I didn't realize I was doing
the moment and I listen I go oh my god
and I remember in my head going dude
you're here on 3rd you're in first base
you're looking at third already you
missed second base
you're not even that you're not even the
moment that's hard because there's I go
you never know how you should think when
you're on stage you're doing the bit and
you're just trying to perform the bit
right and if it's going well then you
start saying okay this is going well
what am I gonna lead into next but while
you're still talking about the original
thing you can't do that I know have you
done that before the like yeah no I've
definitely done it you know so
disappointed myself man the big thing
about comedy one of the big things is
the audience has to know that you are
honestly thinking about that subject
like even if you talked about it a
hundred times when you're talking about
it that day in front of those people
they want they they're hearing it for
the first time they want you to be tuned
into that subject 100% and present yeah
if you're not they can sense it else I
know I'm so disappointed my so I've
never done it before and it was it's
very strange to because and this is what
hurts me about the Edwards situation is
the guys I looked up to yourself Garry
Shandling like they always help people
man you don't put anyone down they
always help people and I
same platform you guys have but I like
to think one day I well and I want to
help people like you guys tell people
like there's the 60 degrees of
separation and you look at all the lives
you've touched and Garry Shandling it's
it's insane that's so inspirational to
me and I was watching the Garry
Shandling doc I want man that's so cool
and that's why this Edwards situations
[ __ ] me up cousin like damn man it's
not I don't want to hurt anyone but with
you back to the comedy I was so excited
that Garry Shandling stuff when they
whenever they get a channeling whenever
they show calmly store stuff it's just
I'm so into it man he's talking about
the economy store and I got super
inspired and I was like let's do this
I've never been more pumped to hit the
stage and then that happened I'm so
disappointed